how are you doing today hi steve
i'm well how are you
it is very nice to see you again to talk
about the morning show thank you same
uh so i'm gonna start with i've seen all
of season two uh it's fantastic
i think that fans are gonna love it and
i'm done i will see you later you made
my day
as someone now who has seen all of
season two um i'm gonna ask this as a
fan uh where are you in the development
of season three because i'm ready
well we are still dealing with season
two uh season three who knows you know
we are i'm still i'm mixing season i'm
i'm mixing episode 10 on monday uh i'm
still dropping music in
you know um you saw it in a very kind of
naked state and i'm still thrilled that
you liked it so much
it's it's really hard to
imagine what season three will be
still
being in season two
no i i completely get it and yeah i've
seen enough in rough rougher conditions
than what i watched see the ending of
season you know what i mean it is still
so easy to follow um because it's about
the acting and about the dialogue and
the characters it's not about some
special effects you know
exactly and um
even though we did use a lot of sleight
of hand to
make you feel like you were in italy
and uh
you know on the streets of italy and
vegas and
and new york we never left l.a
no no i noticed that but you know i
wasn't going to say anything
so you directed i believe four episodes
in season two
and i'm curious how did you decide which
episodes that you wanted to helm and did
you cherry pick any because you're like
well i want i want that one
yeah i cherry pick of course um i wanted
obviously to do the first two it's like
a
movie you just
you know um it was important to to
explore the beginning of the season it
was very important to do the finale and
i really wanted to do
the episode where
um
where alex uh goes to italy and uh i
really wanted to explore that storyline
with mitch kessler you know because we
do not exonerate him we do not forgive
him
um
and it's just really an interesting
storyline
when you've had a relationship with
somebody for 15 years who's done
horrible things
and do you still have love for that
person does you know alex actually has
gone there
for him to refute
what's going to be in that tell-all book
and
you know you look at this
this disaster of a relationship and of a
life
um
and you think can things be what they
used to be and they can never be what
they used to be
and um you know it's interesting do you
stop loving a person who's done such
horrible things
yeah and i think that's one of the
things the show does very successfully
is dealing with these things that
normally maybe get pushed off and you
don't confront but uh i'm curious so you
originally start filming the series when
covet hits and then all of a sudden you
have to shut down and i know the scripts
got reworked i'm curious how much did
the storyline
what was for example the original finale
of season two were you had you not
figured that out yet in terms of you
know what i mean yeah i mean i don't
remember what it was
honestly i don't it was not written yet
uh you know a lot of the scripts had
been written
and
you know we just i you know it was very
important to explore identity and when
coveted hit the world changed and we had
to change with it so it was very very
important to incorporate
covet and
and and
deal with it
in the in the time period that we
understood because
you know we understood it from them
from three months before you know our
charac you know our characters
uh we could tell that story up to
when we shut down when coveted hit and
we understood that we wanted to tell the
story before
that happened before the revolution
before george floyd's murder before
black lives matter we wanted
we understood that we didn't know where
we were going to be
when we aired
we no one knew we were going to still be
in covid
right everybody thought it would be over
but it's not
and who knows when it will be over
but um it was a you know it was a kind
of tough decision to make in terms of
how much of covet do you talk about
you know and you know with the press
also
being
caught off guard
we're a new show and we could reflect
and tell that story
yeah and you did it very well um i
already got to stop i'm just gonna
i'm gonna say congrats on the season and
i hope you're making season three soon